a
[Música]
hola quiero invitarte a pensar sobre tu
identidad cuáles son las personas los
sucesos
las historias que le han dado forma a tu
identidad pienso un poco sobre eso
quiero acompañar esta reflexión con
algunas historias de mi vida que pienso
que le han dado forma a mi identidad
tal vez el recuerdo más antiguo que
tengo es de estar en el colegio y que un
profesor nos pidiera que dibujaremos a
los incas recuerdo al puesto todo mi
esfuerzo en dibujar los cazando pescando
y recolectando y el resultado me
sorprendió porque eran personajes que
estaban vivos que se movían a colores
entonces en ese momento creo que fue el
momento en el cual tuve mi primer el
concepto de identidad quería a partir de
ese momento será alguien que dibujara
iba a ser un apasionado del dibujo
ahora
creo que había muchas posibilidades de
que yo fuera un apasionado de la
arqueología también mis dos padres son
arqueólogos o algo conocidos walter alva
y susana menezes y desde muy niño me
llevaron al campo a las excavaciones
arqueológicas
pero realmente yo no entendía mucho de
lo que pasaba a mi alrededor yo veía
mucha tierra de objetos que no entendía
y realmente si bien todas las
condiciones estaban dadas yo no fui un
apasionado del antiguo perú en el
colegio siempre estaba pensando en
dibujar ni en la casa
siempre está preocupado por los dibujos
animados entonces hablé un poco de el
poder que tiene la televisión sobre
nosotros
recuerdo mucho que en el curso de
historia
teníamos libros con fotos en blanco y
negro y textos que nos decían de qué
color eran esas piezas entonces
realmente creo que todo eso como tal vez
no soy el único al que le ha pasado
no logró calar en mí y no logró generar
interés por las culturas prehispánicas
ahora cuando terminó el colegio
tuve que decidir qué estudiar
en la universidad y realmente me
preocupo no era una decisión importante
era la decisión para mi futuro
mi mamá viendo toda esta preocupación
que tenía se acercó y me ofreció
estudiar a arte porque ella sabía lo
mucho que me gustaba pintar dibujar
y lo pensé mucho y después de eso decidí
estudiar arqueología
porque yo había visto algo en mis padres
en cada almuerzo en cada visita al campo
había visto una pasión por lo que hacía
no se había visto hablar sobre proteger
un sitio arqueológico o resolver un
problema con zip and over que se va a
ser más adelante con todo esto
y yo quería eso yo quería ese sentido de
propósito que ellos tenían entonces en
ese momento yo era un apasionado del
dibujo pero que quería estudiar la
arqueología
cuando ingresé a la universidad
comencé a entender mejor
cómo eran las culturas prehispánicas
junto a mi hermano y tuve la suerte de
en estos primeros años de estudio
conocer a gente que espinoza él era un
artista increíble una gran persona y era
un apasionado por las culturas
prehispánicas él comenzó
a tratar de entender qué era lo que
había en los textiles la cerámica la
piedra y a interpretar estos estos
mensajes de él aprendí a ver las
culturas prehispánicas y los objetos
como cosas vivas a partir de ahí yo
quise hacer dibujos del antiguo perú
ahora casi al final de la universidad me
tocó vivir algo muy duro mi madre
falleció
y eso cambió muchas cosas en mi vida
realmente no sabía qué hacer
regresé a mi casa
mi madre falleció poco antes de que se
inaugurar el proyecto al que ella le
dedicó los últimos dos años de su vida
el museo tumbas reales de sipán
y la casa real
yo
sin saber mucho que hacer visite el
museo cuando ya estaba inaugurado
trate de verlo con otros ojos lo había
visitado antes con mi madre cuando
estaba en producción
pero esta vez trata de trataba de
visitarlo para entender que era lo que
mis padres trataron de plasmar en ese
museo lo que querían transmitir y lo que
mi madre quiso transmitir me en estas
visitas tratando de explicarme cuál era
el proceso de este museo
entendí en primer lugar el poder que
tienen los museos para generar símbolos
de identidad regional lo que podía
ofrecerle un museo como este al
pueblo como lambayeque
y en segundo lugar visitando la casa
real
que fue un proyecto resultado de visitar
los centros poblados los caseríos más
alejados de lambayeque para recuperar
con artistas los rostros de las personas
que eran herederos de estas culturas
prehispánicas
entendí la capacidad que tenía un museo
para colocar a personas que habían sido
discriminadas por su tono de piel por su
fisonomía o por la distancia a la que
viven de una capital
y colocarlos como descendientes de
guerreros de sacerdotes de nobles como
parte de una cultura
orgullosa y sobresaliente entonces
entendí lo que lo que se había tratado
de transmitir y por mi madre es que yo
quise de ahí en adelante ser museólogo
en este camino
acompañado por mi madre y por hendrix
he podido participar en muchos proyectos
proyectos arqueológicos
proyectos de museos
y en esto estuve la suerte de conocer a
muchos amigos de aprender muchas cosas y
de darme cuenta del enorme poder que
tiene el arte sobre los museos
los símbolos que puede crear
uno de esos proyectos es el paseo york
tokio el paseo abierto que nace en la
mente del señor juan manuel gamarra él
tiene una historia de vida increíble él
es un chiclayano que viajó desde muy
joven en alemania vivió toda su vida ya
ella mayor decidió regresar a chiclayo
para criar a sus hijas en su tierra y
comenzó a ver lo que rodeaba a su casa y
comenzó a tratar de mejorar el ambiente
en el que vivirían sus hijas
dentro de esto encuentra el paseo your
tú que bastante descuidado e inicia
gestiones como una persona natural con
el gobierno regional y la municipalidad
para crear un proyecto como el paseo
abierto que en su mente era un museo al
aire libre era la historia de la región
con esculturas entonces comenzó a buscar
asesores y tuve la suerte y el
privilegio de ser considerado como uno
al principio del proyecto realmente me
sentí inseguro y preocupado porque era
un proyecto importantísimo para la
región lo que podía generar
pero me di cuenta que no estaba solo
estaba acompañado de mi madre de
hendrick otra vez y también de todas
estas personas que ha habido conociendo
en mi camino por los museos
entonces se diseñó el paso abierto que
como un espacio donde pudiéramos contar
la historia de la región a través de
varios niveles de lectura y un espacio
lleno de símbolos y de simbología por
ejemplo el paseo your tu que es un paseo
que está
marcado por la acequia por el canal por
el canal your toque y el río que corre
entonces esta acequia your toque como
nuestra historia corre hacia el mar
corre hacia el infinito
cada uno de estos tramos o veredas
están
formados por una imagen que es un live
que es un pez moche que simbolizaba esta
esta esta ciclicidad este retorno
permanente de la historia
también tenemos símbolos como el señor
de sipán frente al viejo señor de sipán
separados por una sequía
esto simboliza un poco la idea de que
nuestros ancestros
influencia en nuestras decisiones en
nuestras acciones nos miran desde el
otro mundo y también como nuestros
ancestros marcan nuestra identidad en el
presente
también el paseo marca por ejemplo un
espacio donde uno puede colocarse en el
medio
rodeado por un lado por los dioses
benéficos y por el otro lado por las
fuerzas de la naturaleza que les son
adversas a las personas no hablando de
esta dualidad del mundo mucho
realizando el paseo y yo tú que me
cuestioné mucho el tema de la identidad
qué es la identidad
la identidad no es algo que se pueda
decir concretamente yo no puedo decirle
tu identidad s estoy entidad es aquello
realmente la identidad es algo que
elegimos cada día y el paso your tú qué
es eso no busca imponer una identidad
sino busca ofrecer una posibilidad más
que puedes sumar a tu identidad la
identidad es algo que elegimos para que
sea parte de nosotros todos los días
por eso hoy puedo decir que yo soy bruno
alba y por mi recorrido mi historia las
personas que he conocido soy alguien que
se dedica a crear imágenes de identidad
regional y nacional esas imágenes que me
haya gustado cuando era niño encontrar
en mis cuadernos del colegio o encontrar
pintadas en la calle
hoy día soy esa persona que hace las
imágenes que necesitaba cuando era niño
qué identidad estás eligiendo tú
[Música]